- How do you deal with the unknown?
Like when it comes to--
- By recognizing I have no fucking choice.
(rap music)
(calming music)
We're not gonna be able to deliver.
This is not the first
impression I wanna make.
I'm running a business here.
You know what I mean?
It's just not what we're doing.
It's like asking the best media analyst
to analyze timber pricing.
(jet noise drowns out conversation)
- [Man On Phone] Aside
from staying consistent,
how would I maintain
this momentum with just,
how much travel my
account's getting right now?
- [Gary] Staying consistent.
Dude, loving the process means that
you're intoxicated with the process.
It's just that, right?
Like, it's not being intoxicated with,
"Wait a minute, I've
hit pay dirt, how do I
"maintain it or grow it more,"
actually giving a fuck
about the process and
staying consistent, that is it.
I'm gonna give you a
really good piece of advice
of this very short period of time.
Be binary about your decisions.
Let me tell you what I mean by that.
Don't overthink jumping
in to your first job
and then quit it the next
day if it doesn't feel right.
That's it, there's nothing else.
That's it.
Don't overthink shit, because
you can literally impose
your thing into anything,
you just don't know
that thing you're jumping in to.
But it's not an end all, be all
if the first one's not right.
- That's the biggest thing.
- [Gary] Nobody's gonna
give a fuck if you've got
four companies on your resume
in the first two years.
No place you wanna end up.
Leaving college, that's gonna happen
for the rest of your life.
And it's no different
than starting high school
and like, picking college.
It's fucking life.
Like, nobody knows what the
fuck's gonna happen tomorrow.
- So, how do you deal with the unknown?
Like, when it comes to--
- By recognizing I have no fucking choice.
- Okay.
- Right?
Like, cause that's actually life.
Like, zero people exist.
- Are you scared?
Like, do you ever fear the unknown?
- Nope.
- That's what my main thing
is, like with every aspect--
- Because I'm confident.
- Yeah, totally.
- I'm not scared because I
know I can handle anything.
- That's awesome.
- You know?
And I know I can handle
anything because I'm
grateful for everything I've got,
and I never envy and want anything else,
and I'm driven by that,
and I'm an optimist.
Like, if something bad happens tomorrow,
I would default into thinking,
"Well, I'm so grateful that
I've had it for this long."
Instead of like, "Why did it go away?"
- It's all about the
way you think about it.
- A hundred percent, and
you can chip away at that.
I mean, to realize
what's practical and not.
- I know.
- This is an insecure game.
Every time you let somebody's
voice get into your head,
and their opinion or what they're doing,
you'll become insecure.
Every time you're just
about you with yourself
and just you, you'll win.
Confidence is only about loving yourself.
- What about the politics of everything?
- They're real, but a
funny thing happens when
you're not listening.
You know, you can hear your
brother's points of view,
you can hear your mom's points of view,
you can hear your
roommate's points of view,
you can hear my point of view, but like
when you're actually not
listening, you're not listening.
I think everybody's trying
to like, control shit
that you can't control.
I'm about to change open
door policy and force
time with everybody, cause it's my job.
Your job is not (censored),
or (censored), or anybody
you interact with to come to you,
it's your job at how high
up in leadership you are,
it's your job to go and figure out
your vulnerabilities,
if they exist or not.
It starts with me, everything's my fault.
I mean, into the fucking most
of my life is fucking me,
every single thing is my fault.
- I don't know if we're staying or going.
- We're staying.
- Taylor let me come in here
so I guess we're staying.
Hi.
- Good to see ya.
- I'm so happy to see you.
- Good.
- I feel better already just
sitting in here with you.
- Makes me happy.
- Also, usually you do
this thing where I talk
to you and like pretend to
understand everything you say,
(laughter) but today I'm gonna actually--
- You're making a commitment to be like,
"I don't get that, clarify that."
- Yeah, to say it.
- Good.
Like, by the way, took me a
long time to be good at that.
I used to be a very much
like, "Yeah, I got it."
I hate that, I've gotten
so much better in the
last three or four years.
Cool.
(relaxing music)